[Musique]
déjà situé à coignières holt rice vient
de changer de magasin passant de 480 m²
à 1200 mètres carrés une surface
commerciale dédiée aux vélos aux
activités extérieures avec un atelier de
réparation et plein de nouveautés hall
tricks une start-up devenue grande pour
en parler nous sommes avec gary ans à
son fondateur bonjour bonjour
[Musique]
alors quel bilan de l'année 2021 faites
vous alors un beau bilan c'est une année
contre l'autre sur proche des 30 % de
croissance on a recruté environ 100
collaborateurs sur l'année et on a
ouvert sur la fin d'année de trois
nouveaux magasins dont une refonte où
nous sommes aujourd'hui du coup vous
avez aussi un partenariat que vous avez
pu tester cette année avec décathlon
vous avez aussi racheter 30 vélos c'est
ça exactement donc décathlon alors
effectivement c'est notre partenaire
actionnaires on est très libre autonome
aux côtés du groupe troc vélo en est un
bel exemple on a fait l'acquisition en
février troglos ses leaders du vélo dans
l'occasion est donc c'est pour nous un
réel projet parce qu'on a envie
d'accélérer dans la partie circularité
donc plutôt de le faire en partant de
zéro on a décidé de faire l'acquisition
du leader en la matière comment ça s'est
passé qu'est ce que vous a apporté ces
deux partenariats qu est-ce qui vous ont
apporté
décathlon c'est d'être aux côtés d'un
partenaire qui comprenne notre métier
nos enjeux et qui nous soutient dans
notre stratégie
troc vélo c'est un c'est une opportunité
d'accélérer beaucoup plus vite et de
racheter une marque est déjà très forte
sur son segment avec une communauté
parce que c'est plus de quasiment
millions d'utilisateurs et plus de 60000
annonce au quotidien présente sur la
plateforme et donc de pouvoir jouer sur
ce qu'on fait depuis treize ans le neuf
et la partie occasions et crée donc
cette circularité dont je parlais entre
les deux vous en parliez vous êtes vous
avez 13 ans d'existence vous avez été
créée en 2008 vous l'avez créé
commencent à évoluer tout ça il ya
vraiment j'étais seul dans un garage
aujourd'hui j'ai la chance d'être aux
côtés d'un peu plus de 300
collaborateurs
créative géniaux passionnés et donc ça
vous a amené en 2021 clôturer l'année un
peu au dessus des 170 millions d'oeufs
le volume d'affaires l'aventuré
entreprenariale a commencé sur le
digital
aujourd'hui vous investissez dans des
magasins réels disons du concret du
présentiel vous agrandissez même
certains magasins en présentiel vous
êtes un peu à contre-courant de ce qui
se passe aujourd'hui en fait à travers
la crise sanitaire
c'est un projet qui est piloté depuis
quelques années qu'on appelle owni canal
chez nous l'enjeu c'est de pouvoir être
présents sur les différents formats
existants au contact de nos utilisateurs
effectivement depuis un an ou deux on
est en décalage parce que le monde du
retail physique a plutôt tendance à se
digitalise et pour faire face
malheureusement aux vagues qu'on connaît
sur les contextes sanitaires dont on
parle inverse on a besoin de contacts on
a besoin de monter nos produits on a
besoin de mettre à disposition du
service en local et donc dans cette
logique là parce qu'on est déjà plutôt
musclé sur la partie digital c'est de
venir aux quatre coins de la france
maillet une présence à travers des
magasins qui font 300 à 1200 mètres
carrés comme celui où nous sommes quelle
est la part aujourd'hui d'un chiffre
d'affaires sur le digital et sur le
présence hier encore les grandes dans
les grandes masses c'est 5% côté retail
physique et 95 encore en ligne et du
coup quel est l'objectif à travers cette
stratégie n'est décrit la scène
l'objectif c'est de toujours contenté
l'utilisateur et d'augmenter
l'expérience client donc je peux avoir
acheté un produit en ligne mais j'ai
besoin d'un entretien en local je peux
avoir besoin d'un conseil pour me
décider dont je vais peut-être aller le
chercher en local
j'ai besoin d'être ajustés sur ma
posture d'avoir des capteurs on appelle
ces études posturales ou d'étudier ma
foulée pour savoir quel est le produit
qui correspond le mieux en vélo ou en
running à mon utilisation je vais la
voir en local ça va être plus simple
aussi c'est une possibilité pour nous de
créer de la communauté locale d
activation pour partager avec nos
utilisateurs et donc en quelques
chiffres c'est quoi l'ambition d'un à
six magasins on en aura huit si on se
reparle en milieu
en milieu d'année et probablement 15
d'ici 4-5 ans alors justement parlons de
cette année 2022 quelles vont être les
grandes dates de cette année 2022 pour
all tricks alors les grands d'alsace et
effectivement cette acquisition troglos
qui encore assez récente on va fêter les
un an dans un mois on vient de sortir la
nouvelle version du site là
qu'on a besoin encore des taux fait donc
c'est une grosse accélération sur la
partie occasion c'est je pense un moment
de respiration aussi sur la partie
retail pour monte en puissance sur nos
différents magasins et puis ça sera
aussi l'année de l'international parce
que pour eux le trx l'international
c'est un peu plus de 20% on veut
augmenter cette part là on est présent
en allemagne en espagne en italie et on
a besoin de rendre la marque le trx plus
visible à l'échelle européenne c'est
tout ce qu'on vous souhaite gagner en
scène merci beaucoup merci à vous de
nous avoir reçus ici et on voit tout de
suite rejoindre sébastien chartier le
responsable de cette boutique pour
découvrir ce nouveau magasin un concept
magasin parce qu'on voit que c'est assez
particulier et voir que hall triste est
en train de changer de deux plateaux
comme on dit qu'on espère
[Musique]
bonjour sébastien chartier bonjour
nouvelle boutique plus grande que le
dernier magasin à coignières afrique de
nombreuses nouveautés tout à fait donc
aujourd'hui on a on a triplé la surface
du magasin pour pouvoir donner un peu
plus d'espacé à chaque univers donc
aujourd'hui on a dessiné un peu tous les
univers dans le magasin on a rajouté
aussi des univers qu'on travaillait très
bien sur le site et que je ne pouvais
malheureusement plus travailler en
physique notamment le running et
l'outdoor si une part important que ça
de du marché symétrie cpt a aujourd'hui
c'est ça ça reste une très grosse part
de marché et c'est aussi une activité
complémentaire du cycliste d'accord
parce qu'il ya des personnes qui font du
vélo mais aussi du réunit les gens qui
assure t il tout à fait il ya des gens
qui font du très athlon donc là ils font
les disciplines il ya des gens aussi qui
font du coup ce lot d'or avait avait un
rapport avec tous les sports extérieurs
voyage à vélo et c'est donc aujourd'hui
entre le gravel le vtt tout la part
montagne ça a du sens puis une partie
aussi alors nouvelle non parce que vous
faites ça depuis mai devine 2021
geoffroy une partie second life c'est le
l'économie circulaire dans le trip tout
à fait donc aujourd'hui maintenant qu'on
a beaucoup plus de place on peut se
permettre de reprendre beaucoup plus de
vélo sur place donc
c'est ma seconde la présence de coups
aujourd'hui on rachète les vélos des
clients
tous les vélos anciens ou même les gens
qui veulent s'en séparer partir sur
autre chose donc aujourd'hui le client
vient avec son vélo ont fait une
estimation on fait les réparations s'il
ya lieu d'en avoir et derrière on lui
rachète son vélo il peut repartir sur un
vélo neuf ou alors on peut lui racheter
tout simplement son vélo et derrière on
leur propose à la vente avec une
garantie supplémentaire et c'est ce
qu'on voit ici en fait c'est ça c'est
celeno là alors il ya de tout il ya du
vélo électrique je suppose et du vtt et
du vélo de route enfants tous types de
vélos que ce soit du vélo enfant aux
vélos adultes de route vtt tous types de
vélos est bienvenue et donc c'est pressé
des petites réparations ça peut être sûr
par exemple le pneu s'appelait ça peut
être effectivement il faut que les bleus
puissent durer au moins une bonne année
suivant le kilométrage défini que la
transmission elles soient récentes voire
neuf donc quand les vélos viennent avec
des transmissions vraiment très usagers
on repart sur du neuf alors combien de
personnes ont été embauchées suite à
l'ouverture de ce magasin indécente
c'est ça le oui c'est ça y est on a
ouvert depuis mi décembre
donc on a embauché deux personnes
supplémentaires et on a une prévision
d'embauché encore deux autres personnes
cette année qu'est ce qu'on peut vous
souhaiter pour 2022 sébastien bach
beaucoup de vélo beaucoup de clients
voilà je dirais météo propice à
l'activité du plein air merci sébastien
chartier de rien responsable du magasin
holt rixe à coignières et le sky échos
se poursuit
[Musique]